do you mean government government
everything so like for example if
someone gets fat there's fat phobic if
someone has a high body count sleeps
around they're slut-shaming like they
don't have the equivalent of that for
men um in this instance i'm saying like
you get money from the government i just
believe or
because i don't personally take child
support right
right with my baby father but that's the
choice i made and i'm dealing with it no
and that's that's the thing i respect
people that take accountability but it's
like it's like to me i don't think
anyone should bail anyone out for their
bad decisions so if you choose to make a
child with a less a subpar guy i don't
think you're entitled to his money you
should have picked better but then the
man's played just as much of a part to
create that child as the woman no no
because women are in charge of birth
it's your own fault if you get pregnant
because because we have we have 10 to 15
forms of birth control even if we get
pregnant you can get an abortion